you know there's summer and spring and
winter but fall it's definitely the best
season and I'm gonna tell you why follow
means sweater weather everyone looks
good in sweaters look at this tiny human
girl that should be you let's get real
pumpkin spices Oscar and goes with
everything
grab yourself a steamy cup of pumpkin
spice latte and treat yourself fall also
means county fairs are popping up left
and right they are fun they are cheap go
grab yourself some funnel cake all right
now ferris wheel you know pretty it is
don't tell me you forgot about
Thanksgiving that is the best you get to
eat so much food with so many people
that you like hmm look at this lady she
has never been happier in her entire
life it was because the trees go from
normal-looking things into majestic
creatures I said hey if you're allergic
to the outdoors and can't do all of that
guess what ball means great stuff
indoors too small T V oh my gosh girl
what are we watching tonight is it
chunda there you have it so many reasons
my fall is the best season ever don't
mind me I'm gonna go eat something
pretty clean some leaves you can to see
out there
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]